we have a voicemail number.
You can call that number at any time of the
day.
If you get a hankering, uh, for some fried
chicken in the middle of the night and you
stumble over to the kitchen and you say, I'm
going to leave 12 voicemails for the David
Pakman show, you can do that.
And many people do.
You should see what the mornings are like
going through the voicemails that came in.
We got a voicemail very late in the evening
last night.
That is just a full blown conspiracy theorist
who, who wants more conspiracy talk on the
David Pakman show quite simply.
Let's take a listen to it.
Hey, it sounds a little bit about Seth rich.
Okay.
Oh, and the server, right?
Let's talk a little bit later.
Yeah.
Well, it's gonna have to be much, much later
because we don't, uh, we, we, we aren't, um,
uh, perpetuating the conspiracy theories that
Rudy Giuliani is going on Fox news to try
to perpetuate that Donald Trump is tweeting
about.
We don't, do, you know, let's have a big conversation
about issues.
Like why do the family members of politicians
get these highly paid, uh, lucrative gigs
for which they really only have access to
which they really only have access because
of their family members being in positions
of power.
That's a big picture conversation.
I'm more than glad to have, and we can have
it about Donald Trump's family.
Um, you know, when, when, when you ask the
question of Hunter Biden, would you be on
the board of Barisma if Joe Biden weren't
your dad?
The answer is no.
When you ask Ivanka Trump, would you be sitting
in for the secretary of state if Donald Trump
weren't your dad?
The answer is an even more resoundingly no.
And we can have that conversation.
It is not what Donald Trump's impeachment
is about.
And that's the important thing to remember,
which hopefully is a starting to get through
in some way, shape or form.
We've got a great bonus show planned for you
today.
The Grammy's had a 12 year low rating on Sunday.
I didn't even know the Grammys were on Sunday.
I didn't see any promos for the Grammys.
I didn't know that the Grammys were on Sunday.
I found out when I read an article about the
low ratings that the Grammys were on Sunday,
I believe that increasingly the era of these
awards shows has basically passed.
Now the right also doesn't like these awards
show, but for different reasons.
I don't care about liberal actors saying liberal
things in award shows have at it and then
people can decide whether they want to support
your work or not.
Um, but I have a different view on it, which
we'll talk about on the bonus show also.
Are any of you still eating romaine lettuce?
I think I am getting off of romaine lettuce
based on a very good piece.
I read a couple of days ago in the Boston
globe, which we will talk about in detail
on the bonus show, and it's very ugly.
What's going on with eco lie romaine lettuce.
Now responsible for more eco lie cases than
beef and beef was historically like the source
of Ecolab.
I also want to talk about Donald Trump's latest
nugget of a middle East peace plan.
Um, and does it warrant praise?
Does it warrant criticism?
Does it warrant a little bit of each?
Uh, we'll talk about it on the bonus show.
Don't miss today's bonus show.
I'll be joined by producer Pat Ford there.
Become a member@jointpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show to get instant access
to the bonus show.
I will speak to you that the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.